ted back shortly today we are learning
more about what happened to a 16 year
old who died while out hiking the mother
of quinfice tells us the teenage girl
was alone on the trails on the far west
side this was near lake mead boulevard
in the 215. she spoke with reporter
victoria saha and wants to warn others
about the grave dangers the outdoors can
bring if you aren't prepared
16 year old quinn fike was eager to get
to the top of this mountain right here
behind me by 215 and lake mead the teen
died doing what she loved climbing her
way through the outdoors quinn fike is
being remembered as an outdoor
enthusiast who was no stranger to hiking
mountains she realized that she wanted
to spend every day outside quinn was
recently diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
she had a dexcom reader which is a
continuous glucose monitor
it's embedded in her arm
and it communicates with my phone with
her diagnosis the teen's mindset was
living life to the fullest so on tuesday
evening she begged her mom to let her go
hiking alone the next day at six in the
morning i said if you must
then go on the trails low in our
neighborhood but around 10 a.m something
didn't seem right i started getting
alerts
that her sugars were not in ideal range
fike realized through the life 360 app
quinn had hiked four hours to the top of
the mountain with temps reaching 104 she
wanted quinn to get down how are your
sugars they seem high
she goes mom i'm okay i'm just i'll
hurry down hours passed and with no word
from quinn fike knew something was wrong
rescuers rushed to the scene and she was
not following established trails by
seven wednesday night quinn's body was
found on a ledge fike believes she died
from a fall getting to the peak of that
summit even on well-established trails
requires some technical climbing and
spotters
and she did it by herself with this
grave outcome fike wants to let every
hiking enthusiast to know never go
hiking alone so no family has to go
through the same heartache reporting
near lone mountain victoria zaha live
local now
we are still awaiting an official cause
of death from the clark county coroner